I'm excited today to talk to you about
uh how you could you know Bridge the
classic world of machine learning kind
of pipelines with the world of llms uh
for those you are online and and
listening um I'm just going to publish a
quick poll just to would be great if you
could answer just to give us a bit of a
sense of you know who you are uh and
then otherwise uh in terms of just a
little bit why you're answering that a
little bit about us Elijah and I you
know collectively have almost 25 years
of experience building kind of machine
learning and data platform systems uh
I've spent most of my career to can valy
Elijah as well also he spent some time
in New York uh we work together at
stitchfix for a long time and that's
where uh you know some of the learnings
uh that will imbue on you come come from
at Stitch building um tools for over 100
other scientists one of the things that
we built there and the only thing that
we open source was Hamilton uh and then
we you know uh decided to start a
company around it uh for the thank you
for everyone for for answering the poll
some results coming in uh it's useful I
see most people uh
are using um ml others are you know just
starting to do llms cool uh so llms you
know roughly a year ago no one really
knew what these were but in the last
year this this kind of space has been on
fire right um and so it's very nent uh
very hot topic and so which case you
know uh for those of you who who know
kind of classic Ile or or debling with
with going straight to lmms there you
might be trying to think you know is
there are these two things the same uh
or are they pretty different
uh and so in this talk we hope we'll
give you two things one is a mental
model uh to help kind of you know
mentally equate these two things and how
they're kind of you know pretty similar
and then also a tool set uh that you can
use for both which Hamilton which will
be uh you know the second part of the
talk U so in this first part I really
just want tow you leave you with some
sort of mental model uh that roughly
equates you know machine learning
pipelines with with LM
ones uh so and by doing that um and I
guess one thing to note is this is a 25
minute talk so and we have two parts so
we aren't going to dive too deeply into
things um but uh in so which case you
know apologize that if you're looking
for something a little deeper but um
otherwise let's compare some pipelines
to kind of see how you know we can
equate these two kind of worlds first
let's start with
inference uh uh say we have you know an
LTV we're trying to do long-term value
prediction which is classic McAn case
and say we're doing some tech
summarization
uh to do inference here from a pipeline
a lot things you you think about and you
need to do you know they're pretty
similar uh you need some inputs and one
you you you do feat engineer the other
one you you pass things into a prompt
you then pass it to a model and then you
get some output uh looks pretty similar
right um one thing to note though is you
know there really isn't any feature
engineering uh so to speak uh with uh
LMS instead you kind of have this uh you
know prompt that you kind of then fill
in with some sort of context in terms of
you know what actually constitutes a
model right this is where I think the
two words are you know the most
different uh in the classic case you
have uh some weights and some features
that represent a model and the llm it's
really uh world it's like a prompt
template that you fill with text along
with an llm foundational model PA
together constitutes a a model um uh uh
and because of like uh you know
therefore it's uh a new model it's just
a matter of tweaking you know a template
and so the way that I like to think
about it is uh a prompt template is a
bit like a hyper parameter
um and so together with an API you get a
model right um and because of that the
iteration Pace it's much different uh so
with the LM world it's much easy to get
to production and build something versus
in the classic kind of ml case um but in
terms of one things are in production
you still have the same kind of concerns
so how do you version the model how do
you know what's in production how do you
understand you know what it was today
versus you know six months ago if you're
like looking for changes right uh you
still have the same observability and
your evaluation needs so making sure
that the output matches your
expectations uh having the same
observability on inputs to help you
debug things and then obviously
connecting the outputs with some sort of
you know business metric or something
that you need to evaluate to ensure that
actually you know uh not that they're
only doing things correctly but then
also that they're moving things in the
right direction for you in your
business uh in terms of deployment or
you know serving infrastructure Etc like
there's nothing really new here you know
uh people were already dealing with apis
for inference uh the only real kind of
difference is that if you're doing any
llm stuff or you're trying to host stuff
internally you're going to need gpus
whereas in the the classic world you
could you know get away with just CPUs
but you know with deep learning and such
you know people have already been using
gpus for serving for a
while in terms of training um uh at a
high level with LMS there really isn't
uh you know much training because uh you
may be doing this you know hyper
parameter tuning where you're you know
tweaking a prompt but in in in the
simplest case there really isn't uh you
know a training pipeline per se um with
LMS whereas compared to Classic you know
ml to create a new model you need this
kind of pipeline to to fit a model uh
but eventually anyone who's doing LMS is
probably going to be doing some fine
tuning this then looks pretty similar in
terms of the pipeline or the structure
that you set up to you know train a
classic Model um you know difference
being you know there really isn't any
feature engineering but you you do need
you know some sort of labeled inputs and
outputs to to uh then be able to fit a
model right which isn't too different
from the classic case uh note though um
you know evaluation is fuzzier with LM
so you're dealing with text those who
come from an NLP background uh you know
know this isn't really anything too new
uh but in terms of time spent if you're
going to be doing this stuff you're
going to be spending a lot more time
eval on evaluation and trying to get
that right with LMS and then then say
the classic cases it were uh and then
from a training perspective you need
gpus if you ever do anything with LMS
yourself whereas in the Cass case you
could get away with just
CPUs um just to compare something more
complex so a recommendation system
versus say a retrieval augmented
generation system so example of that is
say Stitch fix where they were
recommending close there was a
recommendation system for it in the LMS
you might be doing a knowledge you know
question answering kind of use case um
both of these you know actually look
pretty similar in structure again um
nothing really too new both of them you
have some sort of query that then you're
getting some candidate set for and one
it's you know uh items to kind of rank
and feature engineer the other is to get
features for and and the other is you
know taking some text getting embedding
and finding you know some more documents
you're then you know uh potentially
ranking filtering them and then passing
it to a model that then kind of spits
out an output um and
so the model in the classic case you
know rer ranks all the items potentially
but in an LM you you're take you're
providing that as input and and then the
the LM is figuring out you know what to
use from that to then you know provide
an output you have the same production
isation concerns that you need an
engineer for right uh you need you have
the same kind of debugging concerns
observability evaluation so you need the
same kind of hooks and systems in place
to you understand whether things are
working uh you need to connect this with
some sort of data store uh feature
stores a vector database or database you
know um Vector databases aren't actually
anything new they've actually existed in
the classic world right uh they just
come to the Forefront since you know um
since there's a a larger need for them
in in the LM case and then you're going
to be backing these up with some sort of
ETL or extract transform load process or
pipeline to you know feed in and you
know take items and create features and
then in the LM case you know say take
PDFs embed them and put them into a
place that you can then you know search
over
them um uh in terms of the classic world
you know to get something to production
classically requires a a lot of
engineering it's a famous paper by
Google uh that kind of shows the point
being that you know your machine
learning code is pretty small but uh you
you have to engineer and write a lot of
other software uh to kind of you know
get this kind of machine learning stuff
to production um and so uh invariably
this there still uh you
know there's still the problem of you
know pipeline inheritance so most people
don't like inheriting someone else's uh
machine learning pipeline code right and
it's um because of this kind of
requirement of you still have to
engineer a lot uh our kind of you know
high level take on this is you know what
we've seen at stitchfix in our careers
is that usually this is uh because you
know people have over engineered
attractions or um they essentially make
it hard to a uh test uh quickly that you
are changing something you're not going
to impact something Downstream uh it's
going to be hard for you to potentially
swap out a component or you know make
things kind of a modular uh and then in
machine learning uh you know say F
engineering you know how do you make
sure that you can classically or easily
kind of reuse things this can this uh
can become pretty difficult uh if you're
dealing with you know kind of custom
house attractions that most people end
up
Engineering in the Alin World
unfortunately uh it doesn't really
simplify any of this kind of software
engineering requirement right the thing
that you kind of want to add uh for into
your pipelines are going to be uh you
know similarly require just amount the
same amount of engineering uh the space
is is pretty nent as I said it's only
really been around a year and already
people have you know reacted to over
engineered attractions that you know
made it hard to quickly test and be
confident in something but then also uh
uh you know change something for example
classically prompts uh and you know swap
things out as you need to so for example
Vector databases um uh choosing your
abstraction here can really you know
hinder uh what can do and especially if
the as the field has been moving pretty
quickly uh this is something that people
have been uh
facing in terms of um so this is where
you know directed as at grass Ken um I
think you know hopefully I've shown you
from a pipeline perspective structurally
things are pretty similar and yet they
also with LMS and classic ml you still
need you know you have a soft undering
challenge um uh and so let's talk about
now how we can kind of think about
unifying uh more easily more CL mostly
unified classic ml with LMS as well as
work to solve you know the software
engineering challenges as we'll kind of
see um which helmon kind of helps you
with by modeling things as director Day
cyc graphs uh or or dags uh for those
who don't know what a director day cyc
graph is or a dag it's effectively you
know concept of nodes and edges uh where
nodes represent computation and an edge
represents you know the flow of what
happens to be computed uh
beforehand uh in general uh I want to
say dags are everywhere uh in the code
you write so here I have some procedural
pandis code it is in fact can be modeled
as a direct day Cy graph right um so you
can see here we're you know creating
columns and appending it to a data frame
uh this can uh kind of uh this
computation can be modeled as a direct
CYCC graph uh pretty easily and this is
in fact what your kind of compiler is
kind of doing under the hood anyway um
or interpreter uh if you have if you are
using if you're not new to the word LMS
and you've used a libr such as Lang
chain um you know it has some you know
makes it pretty easy to get something up
and running uh it is in fact you know
just effectively uh stitching together a
few function calls to create a directed
a cyc graph as well um uh it moving on
to you know just to kind of prove the
point a bit more so um machine learning
pipelines you can draw this kind of
diagram of structure of like what's
supposed to happen to kind of fit in a
model classically you would then mement
this in production in something an
orchestration system like airflow which
in fact forces you to also model this as
a directed ay graph um uh but what's
happening within these steps right uh is
actually you know uh you know memo P
lands are in fact a dag of dags uh where
you're at a macro level you're
scheduling you know extracting some data
creating a training set fting a model
doing inference in each one of these
steps you're in fact you know your code
is actually you know can be model
internally as as this kind of micro dag
as well
and so this transfers over to the LM
pipeline world so in the case of the rag
example each one of these discret kind
of computational steps again can be
broken down into you know some sort of
series of micro dags um uh and so to
kind of you know round out this this
part of the talk um hopefully I've kind
of shown you that at a high level uh the
you miss allm pipelines are pretty
broadly equivalent to Classic ml ons uh
you have the same shared software
engineering challenges and production
they concerns to a large extent uh but
the you know point to take home with our
Lambs is that applications can be
developed much faster uh and in fact
your pipelines will have to uh need to
be adjusted to be able to change more
quickly as the field is kind of
progressing uh I briefly blew through
the dag section but at its core you know
um you know classic ML and llms can
workflows or pipelines uh can be modeled
as directed as like graphs and so my hot
take here uh is that um a dag is all you
need right and so in terms of
abstraction if you're writing code and
you can't represent it and it's not
easily represented as a dag then the
rest of that is an over engineered
abstraction over to you
Elijah thank you you just need there
call um I'm just going to share my
screen the riskiest part of any talk but
I think I got it all right thanks ston
so in part one we talked about the
mental model uh and Justified why dags
are favorite word or a really good
abstraction for this in this part we're
going to talk about some tooling that
can help you get started with dags so
we're going to talk about the tool we
created called Hamilton and how you can
use it to represent both ML and llm
pipelines all right so what is Hamilton
well I'm going to throw at you a
definition that's got a lot of words
here so Hamilton is a micro
orchestration framework for defining
dags using declarative functions and
we're going to go over each one of these
pieces in detail but the whole goal of
it is to give you a bunch of sort of
software engineering best practices and
make them really easy so make it easy
for you to build highly testable
self-documenting
pipelines that are very modular and
encourage reuse it's all open source you
can install it on piie uh the package is
called SF Hamilton because it came from
stitchfix where it used to work and you
can try it out uh online at try
hamilton. deev and run in the browser
you don't need to install anything
there's a link to this in the chat
too cool so uh is over micro
orchestration versus macro orchestration
uh macro orchestration handles this
whole thing you might know tools such as
airflow um metaflow they're going to
speaking right after us that think sort
of a macro orchestration level micro
orchestration H handles what happens
inside these steps so the actual logic
how the data flows how it's transformed
and where it's saved that's all the
micro orchestration
piece again uh we showed this but to
hammer home Hamilton dags rep repl Place
procedural codes we have these
operations on a data frame you might be
very familiar with this in term in a
feature engineering context you're
making sort of these monolithic changes
this can actually be represented as a
directed asli graph you can see uh to
calculate spend mean all you need to
know is spend and to calculate spend
zero mean all you need to know is spend
mean and spend you don't need to know
the other ones so you have an implicit
ordering with natural set of
dependencies that represents this
computation cool so in Hamilton uh we
deal with declarative functions and
functions declare a what they create in
the dag and B what dependencies are
required for computation so you can but
you don't have to run these functions
directly uh and in Hamilton you don't
actually uh and when you read the
function the idea is you should be able
to understand everything about it what
it does and what it needs and how it
works so this is a notion we call
internally they're called named pieces
of business Logic the idea is every
component of your dag should be nice and
self-contained and really give you a
sense of exactly what's happening
so talked about what it is uh it
actually came from a very specific
problem that you've probably all seen
before which is that of debugging a data
Frame data frames are often created
using a series of complex code and
Transformations and we were having a lot
of trouble figuring out exactly what
happened why one column was wrong so we
wanted to sort of rethink the world and
come up with a way to compute this data
frame the idea was simple what if every
column or every output column in this
case corresponded to exactly one python
function
and what if you could determine the
dependencies from the way that that
function was written so have a onetoone
mapping of function to column that's how
we came up with Hamilton the in Hamilton
the output sort of the column in this
case but it actually works for more than
just data frames and series is
determined by the name of the function
and its dependencies are determined by
the input parameter so uh to turn it
into a node you take the function name
that's the node and the dependencies
form the edges therein is a dag uh this
isn't actually new to Hamilton if you've
seen P test fixtures I think they came
before it uses the exact same sort of
terminology or sort of a structure and
dagster software defined assets came
afterwards which uses a similar
concept so uh how does this compare to
the procedural code we showed you before
well instead of writing it line by line
where you're managing a monolithic data
frame you declare each step as a
function that handles a specific set of
data right so in this case instead of
doing DFC equals DFA dfb DFD equals some
transform you define c and d c depends
on A and B and D depends on C and this
is sort of the entire set of code you
need to
write right so what does the full hello
world look like well we've defined our
functions in the step before and we have
something called a driver that tells you
what and when to
execute so we handle the module so first
you import your module that we defined
above then you instantiate your driver
pass it some data and the
module uh next you actually execute it
you say which nodes you want and
Hamilton's smart enough to just execute
the ones you want upstream and finally
you've got the result so this is the
full hello world you can copy this code
and run it in Hamilton and it should be
pretty
easy there's a lot more to the framework
as well uh we won't go sort of in- depth
into this um but we have a bunch of
decorators that sort of form higher
level operations on top of functions so
you can attach metadata to your
functions you can repeat them with
different parameters uh you can do data
validation the only one that'll be
useful for the rest of this talk is
called config do when and the idea is
you can sort of do conditional
transforms so have uh one trans one
function included in the dag in one case
and one included in the dag in another
case and be able to swap between
them remember Hamilton is also sort of a
new way of writing python functions but
it isn't opinionated about the tools you
use to scale and has all sorts of
natural Integrations with a bunch of
them so you can use any sort of python
object run Hamilton in any python
context and we we've seen things from
running Hamilton on spark Ray dask FL
fast API flask jupyter notebook the
world is your oyster
here cool so let's go over some examples
uh I'm going to talk about how we can do
use Hamilton for sort of more classic ml
then for an llm pipeline then for a
combination of
both all right so let's dive into
feature engineering here the high level
is machine learning and focus a bit on
feature engineering uh sort of feature
ing plus the high level is that we're
going to Define one function per feature
so they're nice and self-contained you
have sort of modular unit testable
components join them together and run
them as part of the Hamilton driver
utilize this config1 decorator I talked
about to swap between online and offline
implementations and expand out to more
components of the machine learning life
cycle okay so here are some features
you've probably seen code that looks
like this uh CU it's just operations on
a panda series but now we've got them
broken out into nice clean functions you
can use in a lot of different places in
this case uh these form a dag together
and as part of a bigger
dag create our sort of whole feature
engineering pipeline which might be one
of those steps in the macro
orchestration framework but now we've
got it nicely uh put together we can
figure out exactly what's happening and
we can understand lineage from a very
fine grain
perspective note that if we have some
features that might be different between
batch and online say you're querying a
service online and you're loading a
table in batch we can use config when to
switch between the two modes in this
case we get our survey result data from
different cases offline from different
uh locations offline and online and we
have client login data that we get from
a service online and load up a table in
batch right so you can use this to keep
most of the feature engineering
pipelines the same for the map functions
that we saw before for the sort of the
simple uh series TOS series functions
and for the more complicated ones you
can switch them
out then it gets pretty easy to add
pieces on top of this so you can add in
machine learning uh inference and
training as needed in this case I'm kind
of making a joke here and just instan a
model for training it but you would
imagine that due to sort of the
modularity and ease of putting new
pieces in the dag you can uh train your
model and then do predictions right
after
that cool let's talk about how this
works for llm
pipelines well if you're familiar with
uh sort of common llm terminology um
you'll notice that you'll not there sort
of anide a called chains which is sort
of little components that you can all
together uh we're calling those
capabilities but the idea is you define
these capabilities or chains as dags and
nodes the functions can form prompts API
calls external data queries data
transformation really whatever it's all
just sort of written in Python and you
can sort of bring your own abstractions
or bring your own
tools then you can sort of tie them
together with a control flow uh that you
create or sort of an agent they can take
the result and feed it to the next EX
execution so manage state or maybe even
use an llm to decide which gag and how
to run the next one and sort of go from
there building it more complex stateful
systems you can swap out between
foundational models Vector stores Etc
all with
config1 so what does this look like
here's a pretty simple dag to capture an
image and I know this is a lot of code
but I'm hoping it's pretty easy to
understand as to what's happening here
we're creating a prompt and then passing
it to open AI right you've probably all
written all sort of seen code that looks
something like this
uh and we've got another one for
generating an image right take a prompt
generate the image from the prompt and
save the image out pretty simple cool so
we've got these and these start to form
a toolbox right of different little dags
that can be used for different llm
capabilities so you can select which dag
to execute based on the context where
you are in the application or what's
happened previously run in the process
and do something with outputs display
them to the user store a state in
context and feedback to the next
execution even can write back to storage
for fine tuning later really you can do
whatever you want it's just these sort
of like building blocks you can even do
what I did and embrace some chaos Fe a
caption from chat GPT to an image
generator in dully with a while loop and
two lines of Hamilton code blog post
coming soon about this and end up with
something really cool uh I was just
having fun with this yesterday
so all right so now let's take a brief
uh look at how you might even combine
llms and ml together and many problems
you hit will require both for instance
say we want to customize embedding we
want to pass pairs of similar and
dissimilar text that we consider for
sort of our space query a foundational
model for the embeddings train a model
on those pairs and then project your
embeddings onto that space right this is
actually comes from the open AI cookbook
you download all this code online we
have uh in the new thing called The
Hamilton Hub that we'll share
shortly and the idea here um you don't
have to really get too into depth into
this because I just put a big pretty dag
to uh show some eye candy but you're in
this this case we're doing both sort of
querying a foundation model and training
a model using classic ml you can swap in
and out pieces use ml for One Piece use
LM for other pieces it's all nice and
modular and broken into
components the idea is to use them for
both of uh both LM and MLS allows you to
bring your own tooling choose which
piece you want for which specific job
swap out the components implementations
Etc visualize test and reuse all those
different components as I showed before
and do all of this with one tool where
you can delegate to whatever other tools
you might need so you're avoiding the
sort of over-engineered abstraction all
right so in summary about Hamilton uh we
wanted to argue or we we're arguing that
modeling your dag as self-descriptive
functions allows you it sort of affords
you a lot right you can use the same
tooling for llm ML and data processing
so you're not Reinventing the wheel
every time you switch between them you
can rewrite in multiple contexts to save
code and headaches reuse dags to build
really cool things things and build all
of the above as modular testable
self-documenting software the goal is to
never fear inheriting somebody else's
code so taking a look back on everything
we talked
about uh the mental model section
pipelin llm pipelines are broadly
equivalent to Classic MLS that's we were
arguing but the llm field is moving CH
changing quickly while traditional
machine learning isn't going away you're
going to need pipelines that you can
easily swap out pieces and manage ild
build quickly you can model ml pipelines
as dags as well as M llm pipelines and
we would argue that it is in fact both
sufficient and necessary to build a
really sort of like strong uh well
modeled system Hamilton can be your
unifying tool set for this uh software
engineering best practices for free and
can do both large language models and
llms and is meant to handle change so
you can easily swap out components
develop it and make changes in test them
against each other so next steps uh you
can download Hamilton on pipod go to try
Hilton all these links are in the chat
go to the hub hub.io to get started with
something quickly St the repository on
GitHub uh we appreciate it let us know
that people are interested and join
slack if you have any questions uh we
also have are going to be around later
to answer questions and are in the chat
so thank you so much I really appreciate
your time and we would love to hear any
questions feel free to reach out to
us Stefan and Elijah thanks so much for
that great talk
so we'll just give it a stuck here to
see if there's any questions that show
up um that was a lot of information you
covered there so yeah we were slightly
ambitious with with what we wanted to
cover but it you did it it's
great oh there's something that's coming
in Q&A did I see that or yeah could you
transform a Hamilton
dag into a something for example an
airflow Dag
yes yeah uh you can there are multiple
yeah I'll take this there are multiple
way this is actually something we've
been working on a lot recently there are
multiple ways you could do it uh the
easiest way is to sort of take a subset
of the dag load data from one place and
write it to another place and then you
have an abstraction where you don't
actually have to think about airf flow
the next thing we're thinking about is
and so you can write like you can call
out the Hamilton inside airf flow and
that's effectively transforming it the
next thing we're thinking about is uh
building actual compilers that could
take a Hamilton dag and compile it to
airflow and then you could say compile
it to metaflow or dagster later on yeah
I just we have a Blog actually on how
you can use H with metaflow so this what
the first step of like how you can
combine the two but yeah it's on the
kind of the road map of like how can we
yeah allow you to group a set of nodes
into one computational task and then you
know help generate the um D flow code
that will then run the Hamil cide for it
good question thanks
son
excellent well if there's uh no more
questions at this time there was sorry
there's something that came
in do you see that in chat if you want
to take a
quick yeah so I if I understand
correctly the conversation is yeah the
question is Hamilton brings added value
to the llm and how does it work uh but
largely to the chain of operations
that's what we're focusing on now so uh
one thing we found is that like we like
talk about over engineered abstractions
agents sound really cool but I think the
biggest thing that people need right now
is sort of well structured code that uh
is resilient towards failure and
Hamilton could help give you that um and
then we have sort of more abstract more
things we're working on in the sort of
agent space that I alluded to um that
we're gonna be developing soon yeah yeah
so like um yeah the the the Hamilton
helps structure you know the capability
of thing you want an agent to do we've
also found that most people for most the
purposes when they want to go to
production end up really heavily
customizing an agent as well and so in
which case there really hasn't been an
abstraction that uh fits well for them
other than you know a hello will demo uh
but you know if you have you know use
cases or or feedback you know we'd love
to learn from you and see how you know
we could uh you know build something on
top of Hamilton for example that is more
agent based that then you know um
fulfills that kind of
requirement great thank you so with that
um thank you everybody for coming to the
session thank you Elijah and Stefan for
that great presentation and
to everyone here um enjoy the rest of Pi
Global take care and we'll end the
session there thank you thanks much